[Music]
footwork in IKEA this week we're going
to be talking about footwork and also
we're gonna push some tiny link Oh in
there when you look at the way I
categorize Aikido the footwork belongs
in a she's Tsubaki and the Tai know
hanko belongs in IP but in lots of ways
they're they're mostly about moving your
body and how that works so we're gonna
kind of mush him together this week the
first thing we're going to talk about is
the basic stance in Aikido most Aikido
schools call this basic stance
hug me that's probably a misnomer it's
not now because that's what I like you
to school's call it but oh since I
probably didn't call it hanmi he
probably called it rope oh no come on
which just means a six-way stance it
doesn't really matter what he calls it
or not but but the problem with that
you're calling it just hanmi we'll leave
this to some confusion later when we get
into the tiny link oh and I think the
the hug me position is so important to
Aikido that the idea was we'll we would
never do anything that didn't involve
hug me first so we must always be upon
me and I think a confusion happened
between calling this the basic stance of
Aikido which is rope no kamae hug me and
hug me which is to actually different
subjects but we're gonna talk a little
bit in this one about hug me and what
hanmi is and what Ropin okema is and and
how those things work so we're gonna hit
all those this week first up though is
the Roku no kamae the basic stance of
Aikido I'm gonna get Josh to come in
here and help me okay so we're gonna
talk a little bit about rope no combine
the basic stance we use in IKEA so I'm
gonna have Josh face you right now enter
open up mine and hike up it's hot but
just a little bit so you can see his
feet okay so in this position
josh is basically now and what you might
call a hundy stance or maybe
traditionally call the Rope Anoka mine
traditional is hard to talk about
because most Aikido schools call this a
hug me so whatever you want to call fish
and pub with that so he's got his lead
foot here and his back foot back here
and if he draws his foot in he hit
roughly the middle or latched half of
his foot and that's basically what a
hund me is some schools you'll see them
turning the front foot out a little in
we're out either way a little bit you
see that sometimes in different schools
we'll talk about why that might be
important or not but but this is a basic
neutral hanmi stance that josh is in
right now now when he's doing this he's
probably gonna want the majority of his
weight towards the front we'll talk
about that a little more in a lot of
videos but this is basically what a
hundy stance is okay so now if I have
Josh face me all right so when Justin
means couldn't since Square right now so
in art school we call this move on me
just without on me without any kind of a
variation in position and I'm staying
right here in front of Josh this is the
way you're generally standing but
understand that the second you go into
action you won't be standing like this
anymore
for example if I were to push Josh
lightly that's the first thing he's
gonna do is he's gonna drop his foot
button back like that so that natural
positioning is the hundy stance or the
rope oh no come on so the basic position
he's going into is that what's nice
about this position is if something
pushes him down he can offer a little
resistance to that right so he can drive
into that so by having a back foot he's
able to immediately push a little more
into me whereas when his feet or neutral
he doesn't have that right to this
position he doesn't have that so when
you're coming into this basic or open oh
c'mon you know I can oh he's just gonna
kick that foot back there for the rokka
rokka mine and go ahead and face them
actually so there we go
as he's facing them he wants to have his
hands in a low position and his forward
foot right here in program like that and
that's making this position now his
hands aren't gonna be high and so a lot
of people will say like oh you know in
modern fighting we've learned that your
hands should go high so in a fighting
situation Josh's hands to go high I
would like to illustrate two points one
is I kid is not about fighting so he
should be doing most of his defense with
his feet moving out of range
even if he were to get into distance
meaning someone's pushing him so hard
generally nike know we're not gonna be
doing any kind of boxing stuff so his
hands up onto his head isn't really
gonna help him because what he needs to
do is get the weapons that would be in
his waist so in Aikido you see these
hands low position right in front like
that that's a basic I did a position of
this he could get to a sword a knife a
gun any kind of weapon he had in belt
range so that's why his hands are going
low because that's where he's going to
go to his offensive or defensive weapons
if
gets pressed that hard so in I think we
don't have high hands because it's not
good if I had a sword and Josh had high
hands I would just go right through
Josh's hands and cut him anyways so his
hands being high isn't important but if
he give to his sword on his waist that
would be important
now that's an old idea but in the modern
era he would be getting to his firearm
so his hands up if I'm shooting at Josh
aren't isn't gonna help them at all
however if you could get to cover he can
go there and his gun coming out can you
lay down suppressive fire so depending
on the situation you're talking about
Mike you know we're always thinking
about weapons are the escalation so
because weapons are the escalation we
don't have high hands we have loading so
in I give the basic Humvee stance is to
have his feet in this position and hands
low right here and right now he's ready
to be into action as far as I can it
goes so this is the Roku mohkumat or the
honey right now at our school we use
them interchangeably because the the
modern era we say honey for this
although I think that's a bit of a
misnomer and we'll cover that by the end
of this week why that's probably a bit
of a misnomer and you and Shiva actually
probably said we're Oakland oh c'mon if
he said anything other than just saying
eh come on I'm Christopher Hine thanks
for watching we'll see you next time